hey guys this is Vadim with max tech and
this is the brand new Galaxy Note 10.1 a
snacks so today we're playing some games
on each one to see which phone is
ultimately the better phone for gaming
we're gonna look at battery life display
quality how hot each phone gets and
other things like that so let's get
right into the game alright so here I am
the Galaxy Note 10.1 I'll show you guys
we're at a hundred percent battery life
right there and we're around eighty to
ninety percent brightness and we can't
hit 60fps and epic so we're gonna go
down to high really can't do 60fps okay
well I guess we're doing epic at thirty
all right here we are in game and so far
everything looks amazing I've got to say
this display is awesome just so bright
colorful and I am experienced I'm
glitching I'm not sure if this is just
the software just the sheer size of this
display is just incredible
oh one thing I'm noticing so far is that
a lot of the volume seems to be coming
from the right side where it has the
main speaker and not as much as coming
from the top side right here about to
hop on this thing it's definitely not
perfect even at 30fps it's still having
issues I wonder if it's just Android
software oh my god this dude I blew him
up alright so here I am on the iPhone
tennis max as you can see the brightness
is just about the same as I know 10 plus
was alright so I'm now here in the
settings and we can reach 60fps on the
iPhone 60fps just feels amazing it also
feels a little bit more comfortable to
hold in the hand as well
alright somebody's in here got that dude
barely
well would you guys see ah come on it's
got sniped you guys see the brightness
just go down like by a ton so as you
guys can see man the colors still look
really good I don't think they pop as
much as on the note 10 plus but they
still look really good and natural and
they definitely pop and one thing for
sure is that the notch does get in your
way a lot more than on the note 10 plus
yep and I'm feeling the back of the
phone and it is hot literally like super
hot I don't think even after an hour the
note 10 + did not get nearly this hot on
the back of the phone
yeah tiem
oh you got me oh man ramaa aw come on
bro
oh alright now let's get into some
asphalt 9 on the Galaxy Note 1000 like a
lot of dropped frames man I'm pretty
sure the Galaxy S 10 plus felt like this
as well so it's got to be something to
do with the software but like it just
does not feel very smooth whoa
three knockdowns right there so I've
been playing for quite a while now and
I've got to say that the back of the
phone feels a little bit warm but
honestly it's a lot cooler than I
expected for playing this line I think
like 40 minutes already however there is
a downside that I've felt and it's
starting to get a little bit
uncomfortable let's talk about our
sponsor Squarespace it's never been so
easy to create your own website there's
a huge variety of templates to choose
from and it's so easy that I personally
created this business site in no time
just click to add basically anything
from image galleries to buttons and
e-commerce products and then you can
easily arrange them so make it with
Squarespace checkout squarespace.com for
a free trial and when you're ready to
launch go to Squarespace comm slash
Mac's tech to save 10% off your first
purchase of a website or domain so since
the note 10 is more boxy like you get
this really big corner right here a very
tight corner and after a while it kind
of starts getting a little bit annoying
now
get into some asphalt 9 on the iPhone
tennis max so as you guys can hear it's
definitely more balanced on both sides
I'm not sure if you guys can hear that
but I definitely can all right I'm gonna
do a drift here oh snap cops everywhere
it'll like me so far this is feeling a
lot more smooth this 60fps is definitely
noticeable compared to what seems like
30 on the galaxy note n plus it is
really unfortunate I mean if both games
can play 60 FPS on the iPhone but they
can't on the note 10 plus that is a huge
disadvantage for the Samsung the phone
definitely isn't as hot as it wasn't
fortnight so it seems like four night is
more demanding and I honestly I really
love how the iPhone 10s max feels in
your hand the corners are very rounded
compared to the very boxy shape really
impressed with how this game plays on
the iPhone tennis max definitely goes to
this phone as the winner for this game
so here we are in modern combat 5 on the
galaxy note 10.1
whoo this is kind of nuts oh he got me
so I've got to say I love the massive
display on this thing well it looks like
it's been exactly an hour and we are
sitting at 83% battery life Wow a full
hour of gameplay all right here we are
in modern combat 5 on the iPhone 10's
max oh all right so what I'm noticing so
far with the iPhone is that just the
gameplay on every single game that I've
played is just so perfectly smooth just
feels amazing but there are some needs
out
come on in Oh whoo gotcha perfect got
him yeah Adam got him yeah Adam Oh got
him all right so we've been playing on
the iPhone tennis max for exactly one
hour and let's look at the battery life
looks like we're at 68% battery life
which is definitely lower than on the
galaxy note n plus the Noah 10 plus
definitely gets much better battery life
it starts with a 4300 milliamp hour
battery compared to only 3,000 174 on
the iPhone 10s max and throughout the
one hour of gaming it only used up 731
milliamp hours compared to a thousand in
16 milliamp hours on the iPhone Tenace
max however there were some perks on the
iPhone tennis max first of all the
gameplay was a lot smoother throughout
all of the games you had higher FPS for
a lot of the games and you have a larger
selection of games because of the iOS
App Store and I also like that the
speakers were more balanced they sounded
better but here's the downside so you've
got the knotch that's really distracting
compared to this little hole punch that
honestly just kind of disappears you
don't really notice it and of course the
display is larger here the colors look
really nice it's really nice and bright
it definitely is a better display on the
note 10 plus and a big issue with the
iPhone during fortnight is that the
display dims just randomly which is
really annoying but in the other games
we did not have that issue at all so
overall which phone is better for gaming
well if you love really awesome battery
life in a huge display that looks really
really good I definitely go for the
Galaxy Note 10.1 tennis max in a larger
variety of games which is really really
nice it feels really amazing gameplay is
really smooth but you do have some
issues in fortnight but other than that
it just feels amazing feels great and
it's more comfortable in your hand so
I'd say if you like a better experience
and you don't really care that much
about the battery life and the display
I'd go for the iPhone tennis max so I
hope you guys enjoyed this comparison if
you haven't already seen our comparison
video between the 1 plus 7 pro the
iPhone and the note 10 plus you should
definitely check out that video and if
you haven't already subscribed click
that button above thanks for watching
and we'll see you in the next video
[Music]